you just groaned if you want to see the
deadly impact of the progressive mind
watch Bernie from last night's Fox News
townhall there he said he wouldn't have
shut down our borders to protect
Americans from disease you know because
that would be racist if you had to would
you close down the borders no I mean
what you don't want to do right now we
have a president who has a propagated
xenophobic anti-immigrant sentiment from
before he was elected what we need to do
is have the scientists take a hard look
at what we need to do there are
communities where the virus is spreading
what does that mean it may mean self
quarantine it may be not having public
assemblies but let's not go back to the
same old thing isn't it interesting that
a president who has been demagoguing and
demonizing immigrants the first thing
that he could think about is closing
down of the border imagine how clueless
you gotta be to say that as other
countries endure chaos due to virus
spread from one travel hub to the next
here you have a leading Democrat saying
that preventing such spread would be
racist against Chinese and Italian
somehow Italians locked themselves down
you idiot
you've heard the phrase fiddling while
Rome burns Bernie's got his head up his
ass while his hair burns
safety first Bernie even for a leftist
Bernie's behind the times by now those
who call Trump racists for blocking
travel have already changed their tune
to a new smear because it worked now
it's he didn't do it fast enough
it exposes their putative politics as
the designation of oppressor versus
oppressed create suspicion in all
relationships black white gay straight
male-female undermining cooperation and
community which prevents action to
reduce death how can you expect to fight
any threat be it a virus or a world war
if your leader wants you to fight each
other
funny how Bernie thought it was so noble
to say how he'd make a vaccine free once
it was available I say why not make it
available now as if things magically
appear before the socialist takes
trol of distribution take it from me
when a scientist makes a drug that helps
the world a socialist will call him a
bigot for taking so long and then smoke
it listen to Bernie Cady we'd be screwed
because the border action bought time
for us to spread out the whatever the
the emergency the urgent hospital prep
and actually make some mistakes well you
know how we're always being lectured
about common sense well shutting down
borders during something that is
becoming pandemic is a common-sense
thing to do the President did it
relatively soon as soon as we knew what
China was telling us about the virus in
January he was criticized for doing so
you cannot as a Democrat or anybody
running for office be an advocate for
open borders where you're just allowing
thousands of people to come into the
country unvetted and then be taken
seriously as a candidate for president
who should be in charge who can do a
better job than President Trump and his
administration has been doing so far
Bernie Sanders talks about scientists
every day the vice president has been
standing up in front of the country in
the world with a number of scientists
and doctors who have been talking about
this disease and the other thing is now
the media is gaslighting everybody
because we call it a Chinese virus or
the Wuhan virus they're saying that that
is now racist which in return allows
China to get away with not having any
accountability for the way this thing
happened Oh
can't talk about how this is China's
fault because that would be racist which
gives the Communist Party a pass for
censoring information for not getting us
the DNA code of the virus soon enough so
we can start working on a vaccine and
figuring out how fast it's going to
spread etcetera etc so this idea that we
can't talk about the facts because
they're racist now apparently it came
from China it's a Chinese virus we need
to deal with it and also saying that not
shutting down borders but also I should
be in charge of preventing the spread of
this is just ridiculous and shouldn't be
taken seriously at least there was the
governor of California Gavin Newsom
actually admitted that what's being done
by Trump is essentially good I think we
have this tape we had a private
conversation but he said we're gonna do
the right thing and you have my support
all of our support logistic Lee and
otherwise
he said everything that I could have
hoped for and we had a very long
conversation and every single thing he
said they followed through on every
single thing his administration and it
starts at the top including the vice
president has been consistent with the
expectation that we repatriate these
passengers it's it's refreshing Dana to
see some kind of unity among people who
are from different political groups well
also because so we have a federalist
system which means that the state and
local governments they're on the front
line so they have to coordinate with the
federal government and if you're Gavin
Newsom do you want to fight with
President ROM or do you want to get what
you need in order to help protect the
people of your state I mean they have
your economy and all of those things and
I think that when things get this
serious and you're dealing with a public
health crisis you can set politics aside
if you want to and in fact I think also
even Governor Inslee of Washington State
has backed off of his criticism because
they realized that we are all in this
together it's not partisan and the
public health workers themselves have
said that the travel ban from China was
actually very helpful because it gave
them the time that they needed right
prepare so we actually I think the
President Trump could have gone further
right you could have said no one from
South Korea
no one from Iran initially but he they
were prudent and they waited and now it
could turn out that it was too late or
something like that somebody might be
able to make that argument but this is a
fast-moving situation and when you're
ahead you have the burden of leadership
which means you're going to get
criticized but I think the facts will
end up telling the full story yeah Jesse
it is a Bernie does have the luxury of
his decisions not not mattering right
Bernie Sanders I'm talking about Bernie
Sanders it's like an arsonist as your
fire chief you don't want someone that
starts fires you want someone that puts
them out you're talking about an
international health scare and he wants
to take away everyone's health care he
wants to vaporize the health insurance
industry he wants to lock up
pharmaceutical executives who are now
racing towards finding a vaccine if you
want to open borders during an
international pandemic that's crazy talk
if tightening the borders saves lives
that's a smart thing that's not racist
that's
Italy did it they're not racist they
trying to get a grip on this thing when
Trump was shutting down the borders and
flights from China the Democrats were
impeaching him and they were calling him
racist
they've been briefing Congress for two
months about this since December they've
been going out forming task force
they've been pushing forth with new
vaccines quarantines everything on TV
every single day what are the Democrats
want to do differently I don't know I've
heard Joe answer that on MSNBC last
night
two-minute answer no clue what his plan
was I had to watch it twice I still
don't know well you know no one knows
what I seem to remember you questioning
whether the travel ban was worthwhile
when we first did it I still think it
first of all it's not shutting down our
borders I hear you guys saying that
there's a difference between containment
which is someplace like Italy and
someone who's saying I'm gonna keep
everybody out because I'm worried
they're gonna bring the disease here the
fact is the disease's already here our
issue is no longer about somehow
containment as the Surgeon General said
yesterday it's about mitigating the
impact of the fact that the in trying to
slow its spread we have a situation here
in New York they've now containing an
area up in New Rochelle that's not about
shutting down its to trying to contain
the spread that's very different so you
have a situation where you know we had
Ebola come in and then Obama was asked
to shut down the borders and all of
course the reactionary said oh yeah shut
down the border shut down the borders
the medical experts said no in fact that
would be ineffective and make it more
likely that Ebola would spread but
yesterday you know what the fact is that
he'd that President Trump knew about
this what was engaged in the it's not
going to be a big deal we still hear the
same thing it's not that big a problem
we'll deal with it it's not going to go
anywhere and of course that was after he
shut it down that he has sacrificed all
his credibility on this issue because
he's engaged and happy thought oh we're
gonna have a vaccine in a few ways out
and panic should that be what he says
like yeah we're all gonna be in trouble
and oh you want somebody on safe
you want somebody to calm you down but
you don't want to be lying and
misinformation he's just not good at
sort of calming us he's exciting I think
the Democrats plan is that you rely on
the scientists on the side no he's
relying on himself everybody think oh
you know what not a problem go to word
ask for shut down the border which was
actually shut down the border he shut
down the Chinese all right all right yes